hey guys first of all I just want to say
we are glad to have you here it's been
great yes and we have noticed that you
have gotten very comfortable and we're
actually comfortable with you're
comfortable I'm so comfortable with you
guys being here but be careful cuz it
sounds like you're injuring yourselves
at night when you're working out and
nine times a very dangerous time to work
out anyway given you know the events of
the last day or so we've revised the
proposal that we had the other day to
something a little more apropos we give
you the day boards force haha the
Gaylords force if you could take the
pain of a Manzi unit pressing in here
you've got the strength to do anything
is one slogan that we're toying with you
know I actually haven't seen this
t-shirt and I don't approve of it okay
but I will be a junior member of the
crew so I should probably audition for
you right now check this out I'm gearing
up for the real thing a freaking phone
book my phone book here I'm so sorry I
don't have it okay so you see where
we're going this right it's basically a
powerful healthy message that being gay
doesn't mean you're weak or uh-hmm
okay what are you doing are you mean sex
with each other we're not having sex
we're just soaking yeah but I think this
soak is about to turn to a power wash so
if you boys would mind scooting along
okay you know what hmm I don't mind
having you here right I don't even mind
all the suckin and they're screwin and
the screamin when you eat jack but I
need to know if you want to be a part of
this show or not cuz if you do I need
you to pull it you get to work it do you
get me okay okay relax sounds cool yeah
we're interested all right yeah
in Graham Hancock none hurts
you